hey everybody I have a special
announcement to make um you may have
heard me say this on my ymh episode but
I am starting a new podcast it's going
to be right here on this YouTube channel
it's called the way back it drops
Thursday January 4th and it will be a
weekly pod every Thursday moving forward
after that all right um it's a Nostalgia
podcast it's a short one too it's a
quick kitter no more than 30 minute
episodes with some of your favorite
guest in comedy and podcast casting we
already have a ton of them recorded uh
I'm very excited to do this if you're a
big fan of the crab Feast if you're a
big fan of the honey do I know you're
going to be a big fan of this show um
it's just something I've always thought
about you know and the set is the back
seat of that old school station wagon
facing traffic looking that way all
right it's the way back cuz we're
sitting in the way back and we're
looking back on things and uh here's a
fun teaser just just to get you excited
about the idea check this out it's the
way back with Ryan sickler right here on
my YouTube channel every Thursday
beginning January
4th there is some of those memories of
childhood that are so fascinating bar
gave us his favorite porno T CU we would
put M8 one of my older brothers used to
fart in my mouth like I can't wear a
diap funny I'll spray fire at my cousin
I got puked on and her boob popped outen
someone's going to die to see like
everything call the Chas not feel safe
holy yeah those were the days that a fun
trip down memory
[Music]
lane